what's going on guys this is rob and
during the filming of this video I was
actually quite nervous so I didn't feel
like I was able to explain ALS as well
as I would like and so what I'd like to
do is take these few minutes to explain
what ALS is for those of you who are
unaware as well as places that you can
go to donate for ALS research so ALS
also referred to as Lou Gehrig's disease
is a neurodegenerative disease meaning
that it causes a breakdown of the
signals that go from the brain to the
spinal cord and what this does is it
causes the individual who's been
diagnosed with ALS to slowly lose motor
function meaning they're unable to
control their muscles now this can cause
paralysis and eventually lead to death
now as far as the diagnosis of this
disease it's actually not nearly as
weapon as a lot of people believe
anywhere between 2 and 100,000 people
can be diagnosed with this but the issue
here is that this is a very debilitating
disease and it is almost always fatal
and so of course this affects not just
the individual who has been diagnosed
with ALS but affects their friends and
family now if you're interested in
donating towards ALS research then you
can go to ALS a org which is the ALS
Association and you can donate whatever
amount of money is comfortable for you
but I think that raising awareness and
donating can definitely helped or go
towards the cause of finding a cure for
this disease with that being said I'm
going to go and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it and I
hope you guys enjoy the upcoming video
where I take the ice bucket challenge
you guys have a good day peace
yeah are you recording yeah okay sorry
what's going on guys this is rob with
Marvel Comics explained I'm really
nervous right now my sister channel is
mean to the ice bucket challenge from
the gear disease those you guys don't
know the gear disease was a degenerative
disease so nervous causes the breakdown
between the brain and the muscles and
gonna be the paralysis and death uh yeah
so all right all right let's do this
tell me man i'ma prove it all right I've
regain my manhood I nominate three
people first person is Benny from comics
Torian second person itself and give you
a little house and the third person is
Harrison Ford all right that's it